hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of the electronic
triple 2014 my name is daniel wire and
i'm delighted to be joined by sega of
america is very own Steven frost sir
good to see you you're here to show off
the first of two demos from the sonic
boom franchise this one coming out on
the November November on Wii U what
we're looking at as the Wii U version
we're really excited about the sonic
boom initiative
it goes beyond games so what's great
about sonic boom a it's a branch off of
the traditional sonic that you've you've
been used to all these years been around
for 20 odd year it's been a bunch of
sonic games there there have been and so
what we're trying to do now is is really
connect these aspects that we've had
sonic in before so the licensing such as
the toys we've got a CG cartoon that
we're building on and then we have this
game here what you're seeing is that we
you and we're building this whole sort
of synergistic unified world around them
so for the first time you know the voice
actors in the cartoon are the same as
the voice actors in the games the world
that you're exploring and the Wii U is
the same that your world you're
exploring in 3ds and in the animation
yeah so we're really excited about that
what you're sort of seeing here and what
separates this game from some of the
past light sonic games is a focus on
coop so not only is this game a return
to the action-adventure genre but it's
built around the co-op experience so at
minimum you always have at least two
characters with you okay and the reason
for that is that two players can play as
them one person can use to take the
gamepad that will you gamepad the other
person can use any other controller
whether it's Wii or Wii U controller so
one player is playing on the TV one
person is playing on the gamepad and the
levels are structured around the unique
sort of character abilities of these
guys so we have teh tails
Amy Sonic and Knuckles for the Wii U
version in this case what you're seeing
is Amy and Sonic and they're using what
sonic tissues was this new ability
called the inner beam is the first time
for Sonic it's sort of this energy lasso
or bungee cord if you will and allows
him to interact with enemies the world
and puzzles in unique and interesting
ways so in the case before in combat for
example you could use the inner beam and
pick up enemies and throw them in this
case of course is pure Sonic running
away from a giant enemy right you see
something like that this Guardian who's
protecting his crystal you just want to
get away from him and so which
about the pacing we don't you know we
don't want to alienate obviously sonic
fans yeah even though we're changing
this formula a bit we want to make sure
that the speed sections are there and we
have enough with them and also the
iconic things such as bounce pads and
food skates that's all in this game and
but we wouldn't want to do is sort of
like slow down and smell the roses right
yeah you know as you're whizzing by a
lot of these environments and past sonic
games you're missing so a lot of cool
stuff right you want to slow down you
want to look at it so now here you are
you have the ability to look at that so
here's so this is a facility that's
underneath the ocean actually you
actually underneath the ocean and what
it is is an ancient race that's business
world's before there was a great war and
they're called the ancients and it's
this classic motif that you've seen in
past sonic games which is nature versus
technology yeah and so sonic force
represents a journey we've got this new
villain called lyric who's a giant snake
built-in armor and he's representing the
love of technology what this plant did
does is it filters out all the junk and
stuff that the the war in the past has
caused on this planet so all the muck
and the gunk that was in the oceans
this plant is basically filtering it out
and restoring it to norm we could use
that stuff right now I agree I think we
could use that and so in the case of
what the basic premise is is that lyric
having been freed you've been in prison
for over a thousand years he's freed and
he's continuing his mission of trying to
find these power crystals that will
power his enemy army and Sonic of course
being the teammates and lovable hero
that he is the saying you know what we
have to go off we gotta get these
crystals before lyric and one of them is
powering this facility here it seems
like obviously like the sonic franchise
for long for long time being around for
a long time put a lot of reboots a lot
of different angles it's been taken it
seems like for better for worse you guys
are definitely leaning into the you know
odd new sonic for a new generation like
part of a lot of people are quite you
know would say that there hasn't been a
good Sonic game in a while what iswhat
do you guys tend to be doing and to be
honest I actually kind of agree with it
is that you are maybe D shackling
yourselves from the responsibility of
what Sonic fans have said they've wanted
for a long time and are just making it
for the new generation of kids and make
a game for them and just forget about
the pressure for sure I mean as you see
in a lot of games that I'm sure
you've seemed demoed here as this focus
on the living room experience is that
family experience right which is why our
partnership with Nintendo is so key
right the Wii U being toward that
family-friendly console and 3s being a
family-friendly handheld on we really
want to capture that sense of two people
whether it's the parents and the kids or
siblings together exploring this world
together finding cool things and what's
neat about it is what you see right here
is Amy because of her ability to
platformer and go on these beams she can
go this way but sonic cannot sonic has a
completely separate paths that go on so
as a single player you have to make
these choices do I want to switch to Amy
because you can switch these between
these characters on the fly can you pick
which characters are with you at the Sun
of eleven no you can and so it's it's
sort of predetermined based off of where
the story structure yes right um so in
most levels it's two characters at a
time however during speed sections
bosses and the hub areas all four
characters are there and you can switch
between them so Amy is here she's doing
her bit a bit of platforming stuff
she's very agile she has a triple jump
that the other characters don't so she's
all about finesse and sonic on the hand
of course is about speed if you were
playing as him you'd be on the other
side of this facility and you'd be doing
sonics of doing his homing attack and
doing speed oriented gameplay on the
other side so hopefully it's a
single-player experience you'll want to
go back play this again take the other
route and find all the collectables and
hidden objects as a two-player
experience you can go through and talk
to each you're like oh my gosh have you
seen what I'm seeing this is cool part
of this section and I was like no I'm
over here doing this stuff and so that
that sense of wonder that sense of
exploration is very key as is sort of
the pacing of the game so we really
think about the pacing we want to have
sort of action and combat and then we
want to slow it down and let you explore
and do things a little bit slower and
then we pick it right back up with
something frenetic and speed based so
it's nothing to say that just from what
we're seeing here is affair to say that
this isn't perhaps the most challenging
game are you aiming for like a younger
audience it is charged with standpoint
that there's a lot of moves for these
characters yeah right there's there's a
whole arsenal of combat moves there's
the inner beam so from that perspective
for sure but we want to make sure in
this game that everyone can really
finish it so we're working on things
like a dynamic sort of difficulty where
it doesn't scale up and make it
difficult it's more so for kids who are
having a point where they're having
frustration so they're having difficulty
and it sort of tailors it down a little
bit and then it brings it right
back up again because the story is sort
of a great story we want to make sure
that everyone sees every in this game we
don't want to be that sort of statistic
where you know 10% of people finish
right we really want to make sure you
see this whole adventure because it's
really great and so we want to tailor it
where it's challenging but very fair
there's no situations where you have
that punishing drop to your death you
know there's always an ulterior speed
section so if you miss something you'll
land in a section that slows you down
but you can get back up again and
continue on your speed route so a lot of
thought was put into that stuff like
that and so in terms of the cartoon
itself I think it's kind of you need to
talk about that when you're talking
about this because they do seem to be an
extremely tied together and when it
would this is launching in November is
that correct correct when events is the
show going off and in terms of like your
your story stuff how how much are the
interweaving it's just before after or
is it for sure so the games posts the
Wii U and the 3s we've seen a little bit
are sort of prequels to the animation
okay and what it is is it sort of
follows the progression and growth of
these team members so sonic right now
the star this game is very much still
the loner he likes to run off he doesn't
think too much about the future and
through the growth in his game and being
exposed to the events that happen where
he's putting his team members in danger
he comes to realization that he needs to
grow up
he needs the teammates like he's
stronger with the team and so it's his
growth as a character and this team
together as friends that sort of sparks
the start of the animation and also not
only that but Eggman so while lyric is
the main bad guy in the game Eggman has
a man's inner big man confirmed yep
angry confirmed no Robotnik ha ha ha
Eggman for sure so but he has a growth
as well so by viewing what lyric has
done and what how you know the things
that lyric has needed to do in order
defeat sonic Eggman grows as a character
as well and becomes far more formidable
and that shapes how he ends up in the
animation as well and so this is coming
out we you yep and 3ds both in November
and the cartoon will be hitting for that
2014-2015 season on Cartoon Network in
the United States awesome I want to get
a couple of quick questions in from our
wonderful audience here certainly and
the GameSpot chat on on Twitter and I
have to ask this question is too funny
Robert has asked has Capcom tried to sue
you for using the name
well no for Sonic Ubu yeah exactly you
know it'd be great if we had that
ability in this game to throw the gals
sort of attack there but no I mean it's
like you know it's just represented I
think of the boom name is sort of the
excitement I think that we have between
this new initiative we wanted something
that encapsulates this new direction and
also we already you've had event each
year in the United States for fans
called sonic boom oh really yes and so
now it's a known quantity there exactly
so we have that every year we'll have
another one this year and and we're
gonna build upon that so sonic booms
been around with us for a while we
wanted to use it because I think it
represents the new initiative well and
so presumably this this CG this TV
series what's going on with it
when abates is not launching again it's
gonna launch it for the 2004 2015 so
it's gonna start this year and it's
gonna be on Cartoon Network we're really
excited about it love the look it's an
all it's an all CG cartoon which is the
first time for Sonic and again we of
course and again the voice a same voice
actors who play it in with its is it the
same voice actors from previous sonic
cartoons as well or is this a new you
guys see pretty much wiping the city non
so a lot of this a lot of stuffin but we
keeping a lot of it consistent guys who
have maintained like the voice of song
hasn't changed the last few games etc so
we're we're taking those guys but you
know we're getting a little bit more
flexibility a little bit more range and
how they're doing their acting um you
know these guys we're gonna give it a
little bit more flexibility in how they
emot-- I mean you'll see that in how the
banter back and forth thing these guys
so we didn't want situation in these
games where you have cinematic where it
pushes the story gameplay with nothing
and then cinematic banter and the
communication between these guys goes
across the level so you'll see in this
level that we're seeing now that
knuckles and Sonic are a little bit at
odds with one another
knuckles actually at the beginning
threatens to basically punch sonic
because we're tired he's got big hands
yeah exactly exactly so we feel that's a
really crucial dynamic and sort of that
banter back and forth really helps to
establish the characters and really also
helps to progress the story beyond just
the cinematics that we have in there so
who's inferring that who's like who's
the person who is choosing the direction
of that narrative stuff is that coming
from the team who are making the TV show
or you guys kind of doing your own thing
and then that's again that's sort of a
very sort of United aspect so we've
always been too long
very closely with the animation team
yeah they came in they saw last up the
foundation that we're building for the
game they're really excited about it and
they helped to build upon that so while
we have writers in all the different
teams who are working this game we
really worked closely with the animation
writers to really make sure again that
the the way the characters interacting
the way they're talking the humor is
very consistent across it the last thing
I want it's like someone who's being
introduced to Sonic for the first time
watching the cartoon and then playing
the games think wow this is very
different it's very consistent very
smooth transition you'll see just how
the acting is and how the pacing is and
how the interaction to the team are very
consistent across all the mediums cool
Steven Krauss thank you so much of
America thank you very much coming up it
seems like like I said earlier the sonic
franchise has gone through some ups and
downs sure over the wall but it seems
like you guys are really I don't know I
think it's probably a good thing to hit
reset on a lot of this stuff and give
him for a new audience yeah actually
we're appreciating about that we're done
with the Wii U version we're gonna go to
the 3ds version in just a second though
and I think we're swapping out
individuals as yeah you're gonna you're
gonna bounce out yeah Stephens only here
for the Wii you just cares about that we
use stuff he doesn't you don't mobile
gaming